-Welcome back to
the "Tonight Show."
I am here with
Chance the Rapper.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now.
We're going to liven up some of
the most boring things
imaginable by turning them into
unforgettable songs
in a game called
"Auto-Tune-Up."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Auto ♪
♪ Tune-up ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Oh, no, no ♪
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
Here's how this works.
We'll each be given a random
boring paragraph
and the words
will appear on screen.
And our job is to turn it into
an awesome song
with the help of auto-tune.
You ready for this?
-Let's go.
-Alright, bud.
I'm up first. Let's see what
I will be auto-tuning.
[ Tones play ]
"Registration Info for a
Music Festival."
That sounds exciting.
Okay.
Alright. Here we go.
♪ Registering is easy
multi-step process ♪
♪ Sign up with your name
and phone number and e-mail ♪
♪ You'll receive an SMS ♪
♪ With your unique code ♪
♪ And a link to purchase ♪
♪ The morning of the presale ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wow. Wow.
-Gonna be hard to top that.
-That is climbing the charts.
Yeah.
Chance, now it is your turn.
Let's see what you get.
[ Tones play ]
[ Laughter ]
-Side Effects of --
-The "Side Effects for
Claritin."
-The "Side Effects
for Claritin."
Yeah, it should be on your
screen.
The "Side Effects of Claritin."
Whenever you guys are ready.
-Alright.
Alright, here we go.
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Common side effects
of Claritin include ♪
♪ Headache, sleepiness,
nervousness ♪
♪ Dry mouth, sore throat,
blurred vision or nosebleed ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You started to get real fast
At one point.
Sleepiness, nervousness --
[ Raps indistinctly ]
Alright. Let's see.
My turn.
Let's see what
I'm going to sing.
Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
"A Description of What
Cryptocurrency Is."
-No one knows.
-Alright, good luck
with this one.
Alright. Here we go.
Let me hear this.
♪♪
♪ Cryptocurrency ♪
♪ Is a decentralized
digital money ♪
♪ Designed to be used ♪
♪ Over the Internet ♪
♪ Popular cryptocurrencies
include ♪
♪ Bitcoin ♪
♪ Ethereum ♪
♪ Dogecoin ♪
♪ And Zcash ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The Zcash was so hard.
The Zcash just went crazy.
-Alright. Last song for you,
Chance. Here we go.
[ Tones play ]
[ Laughter ]
-"eBay Listing for a Used Pool
Cue"? Is that what that says?
-Yeah, eBay listing for a used
pool cue. Sounds very exciting.
Alright. Let's see what you do
with this. Give him the track.
♪♪
-Oh, my God, wow.
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪ This two-piece
cue stick ♪
♪ Is in a very
good condition ♪
♪ There are no cracks
or splinters ♪
♪ Showing anywhere
on this ♪
♪ Anywhere on this ♪
♪ I do not have the keys
for the lock system ♪
♪ for the case ♪
♪ I'm sorry ♪
[ cheers and applause ]
-Chance the rapper,
Everybody!
Check out his concert film,
"Magnificent Coloring World"
Exclusively at AMC theaters
this summer!
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
♪ You don't have the keys ♪
♪ Don't have the keys ♪
♪ No
-♪ The keys ♪
♪ You lost the keys ♪
-♪ I lost the keys ♪